if you're in the Ohio area there's an
apologetics and pmics Conference next
month July 11th through 14th two
churches are hosting tickets are free
but you need to register several of us
are getting there early to record some
videos we've got some epic videos to
record including a reenactment of
Muhammad eating the poison after the
battle of kibar in fact for one of the
videos we need an enraged audience
shouting various things so if you want
to make an appearance in a soon Tobe
classic video with me and AP and vocab
we're recording that on Friday of the
conference for those of you who can't
make it to Ohio don't worry the
conference will be live streamed now if
you're a Jihadi and you're thinking to
yourself wait David wood and AP and
vocab AKA The Prophet Muhammad are going
to be there what an opportunity to fight
the kufar think again
I was in the same area last year and
I've never seen so many people with so
many guns in my entire life so if you
want to take me out better luck next
time try to catch me in California or
New York or at Speaker's Corner or
outside the Dome of the Rock the
organizers are bringing in a bunch of
speakers since they wanted tickets to be
free they set up a give send go to
crowdfund the expenses if you can't go
but you want to chip in so other people
can go and so they can keep these
conferences going please do so there's a
link in the description box so be there
if you can be in one of our videos if
you want to be watch The Sessions online
if you can't be there chip in if you can
hope to see you in Ohio